parlo announces is back online with new
hosting service after month of being
offline the social media platform parlor
relaunched
on monday the company announced that the
site was up and running with a tea party
co-founder serving as interim ceo
mark meckler an attorney political
activist the founder of tea party
patriots replace former ceo and
co-founder john mancy
who was fired by the company's board
earlier this month parlor which has more
than 20 million users was first launched
in august of 2018 is currently back
online for users
and will be available for new users
starting next week according to
publicity available uh whose data the
domain is registered with epic
which also hosts gab another far-right
social media platform last month amazon
web services decided to suspend upstairs
social media platform to fellow moderate
egregious apple and google have three
previously suspended parlor from its app
stores
earlier this month partly terminal okay
so thoughts on this move taking place
i'm not into the extreme movement on
either side so they don't interest me
i'm not interested in parlor
if that company had a brand like what
they're perceived as as maybe someone
that's objective and looking at so you
mean to tell me for a guy that's as
active on social media as you are like
you use it 24 7. you're not on par
parlor yet like i said i'm going to
approach this as a rational human being
and let me get back to my point about
their profile touche
um parlor i look at them if you were to
describe them
they're weak they're they're a sad story
tough luck you know their ex-ceos going
on the rounds complaining about getting
fired
you're going to have x amount of people
that are going to want this where they
can only speak their views and the only
people listening to them
are the exact same people it just should
be called clone.clone.com or something
i'm just not into it i don't think
they're ever going to be
anything that's a huge factor and
especially right now
when the republicans don't have as much
say nationally
i just think they're not that relevant
and and the fact that they're trying
again is great because they were big in
the news a little while ago and that's
good i guess that they found a place
that they can actually
live on some platform but i'm i just
don't look at them as
this is a little burst in the nation we
won't be talking about them in two weeks
question for you
20 million users what percentage are
mega
i'm going to say far right people are um
85 okay
got would you agree with that yeah i
mean okay more maybe i don't know
who in here is on parlor anybody on par
are you on parlor
i mean i set up an account have you ever
posted anything okay have we ever posted
anything i didn't even know we had to
set up an account
you just did it to protect the name so
nobody comes and takes it okay
yeah i've never we've never posted
anything you're not you
no not at all not on parlor eduardo sam
maybe
no okay got it uh so 85 percent
conservative who said that
is that he's guessing guys you know what
can you research to see what percentage
of parlor or mega
it's probably more than that but go
ahead so your thoughts on this just a
couple different things here because
this is this is a
pretty you know winding story number one
uh
for sure you were active on them no
surprisingly let me shock you let's
start with tom i
i could use tom as sort of like a
barometer for like
how far right is this how
center is this because if we've learned
anything from tom
tom is center right obviously
big trump advocate you were you know 33
percent you were
thought he'd still be president you know
i'm just quoting you bro
yeah but just quote you bro point is
tom but he also has you know common
sense and sensibility and he's from the
midwest and he's got
you know that minnesota nice vibe going
on so if it's too far right for tom that
signals to me
all right this thing's going a little
right here at the same token
something and we've said many times here
the riches are in the niches this is
like the
fox news or the oan for social media
so if you want to kind of be in a far
right echo chamber and only hear things
you agree with
go hang out on parlor because there's
going to just you know they're going to
be stirring the pot of everything that
you already believe they're not going to
tell you anything
that you don't want to hear so another
thing that we talked about was
who they're going to kind of bring in to
be the ceo
to make friends with the
big tech of the world i don't know if
this guy uh
mark meckler who is the founder of the
tea party patriots
uh is gonna be the guy to kind of lead
them into the promised land
so something that pat always asks is
who do you want to be who do you want to
be
do you want to be a mega social media
platform like a twitter like a facebook
like an instagram
that has all types of voices and debates
and
a lot of different uh opinions going on
or do you only want to be a far right
echo chamber
who do you want to be if the answer is
we want the mega crowd and we just want
to maga it up all day yeah
then you have your answer if you want to
be bigger then go
go a little broader yeah you know what i
i said that they'll be irrelevant in two
weeks
let me let me rehash that i think
they'll be irrelevant in one week
because
when you go out and you hire as the ceo
the former leader of the tea party
are you kidding me that'd be like the
facebook board
kicking out zuckerberg and bringing in
the founder of myspace i mean it's
the yeah what the teak party i mean they
don't even existed that's exactly the
direction i was about to go
okay so where time just went right now
is exactly
by the way fyi was it fair to say when
tom started he was
further right than thomas today can we
recognize this guy
okay and is it fair to say that when you
first started you were further left
than you are today would you agree with
that yeah a little bit like don't say a
little bit when you when you first
came you were way way different than i
had to put down my
outfit and then join the podcast by the
way if you see a trend here
this podcast what it does is it brings
us more center
and a little bit more to be able to
reason and see arguments okay
i mean that's that's the outcome if you
think what's going on we're becoming a
little bit more reasonable you hear that
folks so so you said something you said
uh i don't even give him two weeks i
give him a week how do you bring the
former leader of tea party et cetera et
cetera okay so
so when they fired a board were you on
it or was it somebody else when we
talked who
was there who was just me and you okay
when they fired
uh the ceo of parlor it was like 32
years old
they fired them so at that time i said
okay we're gonna find out
we're going to find out in the next few
weeks whether the board is
smart or the ceo smart because that was
really outside we're going to find out
so i thought the board was going to go
get a
center ceo to show
the aws services look we're the board
we're just the money guys
we are willing to go this direction but
they came back
and they doubled down and their true
belief system which is what
no we're gonna bring a tea party we're
even gonna go further right and here's
what we're gonna do
guess what you have a choice to do that
but so do they okay
they also have a choice to say no we're
not doing that let me explain why let me
explain let me go a little bit deeper
is parlor or nonprofit no is it a
charity
no is it a uh uh 501 is it a 501 c
okay so when facebook got started was
their outcome to
uh drive more socialistic philosophies
no when facebook got started what was
the idea was called the facebook they
want to rate hot chicks in your college
well no the facebook was the name of
harvard's yearbook that's what's called
the facebook so when you go to harvard
their yearbook is called the facebook so
originally it was called the facebook
and it went through the
what they did and their main focus was
what going through ivy league
students so they went to different ivy
leagues then they opened it up to
universities and after universities open
up to who
the world it wasn't a political legend
it was just hey
here's where we are right myspace same
thing twitter same thing you go through
all these
this is started politically so this is
specifically politically so here's my
question
do you think a socialist would even
think about getting on parlor
i don't know do you think not unless
they're looking for a fight
if they're looking for a fight a
different story but do you think
someone's like let me go in there
because there's a lot of audience that's
going to be willing to share my content
no you're not going to have that so you
know i was i was hoping
the board wouldn't and by the way they
have some smart people part of parlor
they don't have dummies on parlor these
are smart intelligent
people that have done pretty well for
themselves but to go this route i
thought this was a second chance i don't
know what's going to happen with
moving forward i actually
i actually think that they're i i
actually disagree with tom on the one
week two thing two week thing i'll tell
you why
they're carving their niche man like i
said before the riches are in the niches
they said
we can't compete with the instagram with
the snapchat with the tick tock
with the twitter like yeah we're here
for for the right leaning people
that is why we exist we have political
commentary
that is our brand that is our vibe run
with it
if we need to go find a different amazon
web services
go with it now me personally i'm not
hanging out on parlor i'm not
advocating parlor but i understand the
methodology that they're going i mean
it shows it here like they're like no uh
you're gonna ban us we're gonna go bring
a conservative tea party guy and we're
gonna go further
i get that but that's their that's who
they want i get that but you have to
realize
okay so maybe let me give you okay so
let's
let's show it this way okay this is the
silicon valley mafia
okay this is your belief system okay
of where you are right you are far away
from each other they don't like you you
don't like them you think they're
bullying you and silencing you
you think you know they're idiots
socialist whatever you want to call them
there needs to be a mediator okay the
mediator
is the ceo that reports earnings reports
what's going on communicates with these
guys gives them a little peace of mind
and at the same time guys i want to
execute
and grow the company if you get a ceo
here
fine i get it but you go and get a far
right
like i don't like i don't understand
from a ceo stand buddy the ceo has to be
able to like
i have to be able to work both with the
field
and protect them but i have to work with
the carriers for carriers to know i'm
responsible
and i have to work with my investors and
i have to work with my employees
can you imagine if it's just like no
nobody at the field knows what the hell
they're doing no carriers are dumb and
no home office
i just don't understand the logic behind
that yeah i don't get it i'll make one
more point here
i i look at parlor as an app and a
social media platform that was
created from emotion right we want to
have our own our own place we can go and
i think what this is showing you that
these guys over here that are social
media mafia they will control
what's what's where you're allowed to
even put that up i mean there are so
many
obstacles for you if you want to do it
for that and think about any successful
silicon valley company i mean they're
there to make money these guys are so
smart they graduated from harvard
stanford i mean these are the brilliant
most brilliant people on the planet in
some areas
these guys aren't out to make money
they're just like you said an echo
chamber i think they're not even it's
not a good business model i think
they'll be out of business
in less than a year what's different
between and i don't know from a ceo
standpoint
i mean we can talk about what's
different between what they're doing and
what fox news decided to do
years ago everyone's on the left
cnn nbc abc let's go right baby
and we're going to control that audience
no no no no no but i don't know what
roger ailes
and and and those types what's the
difference between these guys
very different climate look when the
climate
changes this is not you know climate
change when the climate changes in any
industry you're a part of
you have to also anticipate and be
prepared for it things change
products change in the insurance
industry regulation changes
in the security you cannot say i don't
care about the new regulation i disagree
because here's what i want to be doing
you know no
it's a different climate today it's fair
to say
the biggest web services is controlled
by who bezos
listen i don't care how much you dislike
the guy you have to go through aws
okay if you say you know
i don't care what they're gonna do we're
gonna put our apps on you know
a a uh metro pcs dude no one uses pcs
you need to be on apple android i don't
care what anybody else says you know
we're gonna
no no you have to be wiser about your
moves let me give you
a proposal if i was sitting on the board
yeah if i'm on the parlor's board here's
what i would have said guys
we have to go win the trust of who
we have to win the trust of our users
who eighty-five percent are what
matters all right far right it's fine we
have to go earn the trust
of the regulators who are silicon valley
we have to win aws we have to win apple
we have to win uh
droid here's what we're doing we're
going to go out there and say
after extreme investigation okay
we hire teams to come and investigate
everything we have deleted
117 000 tweets and we have suspended
you know not tweets messages and we have
suspended 1940
you know users on parlor who use the
following things
and we have them they've been
permanently banned okay
you come out and you say we're
responsible look
when when when early stages when i'm
running the insurance company
and we had a certain people that had bad
quality business
i publicly went and told carriers here's
why i terminated
here's who lost contract with us so then
i went to the field
because they have to now go to mega and
they're going to say you guys have been
you you flipped this is all about money
for you you don't care about the message
you're not about freedom
you don't care about trump you don't
care about this when trump was doing
with you
so do you because you could lose your
backlash you have to go to them and say
guys
listen moving forward we just can't do
this kind of stuff
this behavior i don't care who it is if
it's my own family i have to
make a decision and take a stand we're
building a company
and do we want this company to be in
business or to be out of business we
want to be in business
the following criteria is we cannot do
if it happens we have to terminate you
we're making it very clear this is how
it's going to work out
if you do this if you do this if you do
this freedom of speech doesn't mean i
can go out there and say anything i want
i'm going to take this person out let's
go
no there's there's levels to freedom of
speech now
opinion fine yeah inciting
you crossed the line so i think if they
took that plan
and said hey very simple powerpoint
presentation here's what the board has
done the last four weeks
since parlor was taken on to show
responsibility to the marketplace
want this to this three this five points
we're going to talk about today then let
the market say oh wow and we brought the
co
and we have co-ceos we have this seal
from this side we have this year from
this side
there is ways for these guys to say
let's give them a second chance
and then you go from there i i i think
they missed the mark
i'm going to make a prediction and a
point here the prediction is they will
100 be out of business within a year
they will no longer be
around there is no parlor within 12
months i guarantee i feel so confident
that if they are still in business in
one year i'm buying everyone in this
office a muffin
and two two muffins for the muffin thief
she gets two
because i know she loves the muffins i'm
gonna hook her
and i'm going to tell you why right now
because trump's
extreme followers aren't as loyal as you
think they are
they're loyal when he's in the news when
he's on twitter and he's the rah-rah guy
and you can rally behind him and he's
speaking for you
now he's at mar-a-lago now he's silent
now you don't hear from him
it's not his he's not like some radical
lenin or stalin or somebody that gets a
following this cult-like following
he was there because he was loud he was
saying what people wanted to hear he
knew exactly how to push the buttons of
all these people
if he's not relevant politically there's
no maga
there just isn't they don't care that
much they want their country to be great
but they're not supporting that one
figure
which is what he was parlor has no
chance none
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye